when I started my journey and people
started calling me the Dog Whisperer the
only thing I wanted to do is to teach
people there is no such a thing as a bad
dog
he's safer with me
today I'm still doing what I love but
the pandemic has changed the world
[Music]
hit a record high the
SE dog shelters are empty the bad news
is people
help he doesn't listen to me like the
problem is me what do I do more pushes
more problems right this is why he
doesn't listen to you so many things you
can fix already
the excitement I just want you to get
fit do you know who I am together with
My Superhero pack our mission is to
Teach the World to honor the pack code
honesty integrity and loyalty once you
get this you're gonna have everything
announcement and that's how we create
better humans and better dogs one pack
at a time
[Music]
so I'm on my way to the Lujan family I
have five children three dogs they have
a red zone situation they have a dog
named Kuma who's a Rottweiler who is
going after people dogs and children now
this breed is very special to me because
my kids grew up around Rottweilers so I
know they can come across extremely
dangerous or extremely aggressive if
their needs are not met it's all about
how you take care of them it's all about
how you connect with them this is a very
serious situation it is a definitely a
9-1-1
you ready Upside Down You're Gonna Catch
ready count to three one two three
my name is Conrad this is my wife Lily
we have five children four boys one girl
and we have three dogs Kuma Kawana and
Ahsoka Kawana she's about 14 years old
very motherly she's the Watchdog of the
house
then we have Ahsoka is four months old
she's just playful a puppy just wants to
chew on everything and everybody and
then we have Kuma
is two years old we got him when he was
three and a half months
I always love at first lick I would say
yeah definitely he's very loving to the
children very loving to our family he's
very playful we were the big family with
three dogs walking up and down the block
that's how our neighbors looked at us
but unfortunately we're not able to do
that any longer
we had a break in unfortunately in our
home
and after the break-in everything
changed for us
after the police had left I went into
the backyard to check on the dogs Kawana
started to cower like she was going to
be hit and then we went to talk to Kuma
he would back away kind of unsure so we
knew that something happened but what
happened we we really don't know
things took a turn
for the worse
we started seeing changes in Kuma he
just started barking at everyone
he was less people friendly and then
when we try to play with him out in the
front he lunges at the gate
my wife and I are always like scouting
we see someone coming we're like hey
someone's coming down the block hey
everyone dogs inside we wait for them to
pass and then we bring them back out
he's becoming dog aggressive very
difficult to walk him the minute he sees
a dog he tenses up he'll fixate on them
then he'll try to go after the dog
very strong and if he pulls and that
leash happens to slip out of my hand I
have no doubt in my mind that there
would definitely be a very bad dog fight
he could definitely kill the other dog
because of his size it's worrying
because he used to listen but now he
just he kind of blocks out what we're
saying since we have five children you
know their friends come over recently
when the children were running around
Kuma tried to go after the children now
you have a 110 pound Rottweiler jumping
on a child that was petrifying for us
and that's when we unfortunately had to
Muslim now that his behavior has changed
our our world has changed we're not able
to go on the walks we can't even take
him to a dog park anymore because of the
aggression my children suffer from it
because now their friends don't want to
come over and spend time with them
because everyone's afraid of the dog so
again now we have to lock the dog up and
it just starts to change the whole
dynamics of of a family being together
we're so fragmented right now with
everything that's going on with Kuma
that we really just want to feel whole
again
we've tried all the Avenues that that
were available to us and we really don't
have any other roads to go
sorry there
[Music]
yeah
we don't want to give up but it's just
creating so much stress and so much
anxiety all the time that if we can't
correct it Kuma
um
we'll have to leave our family and I I
cannot imagine
that happening
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
how are you how are you how you doing
sir pretty good really good what do we
have here this is the Lujan family nice
to meet you all okay and then we have
our little puppy Ahsoka Ahsoka we have
our old lady here this is Kawana okay
and then we have the reason why we're
all here the Met himself
Kuma
he's aggressive towards other dogs and
recently we've been seeing that he's
being a little aggressive towards
friends who come over with their
children and that's a big concern for us
the children were running around playing
and he lunged towards our friend's
children okay so it's kind of a ball of
issues that we're hoping that you would
be able to help us with
watch his reaction
this is bad we can't even walk him we go
on pack walks with our friends and we
can't even take Kuma with us because
he's being a little too aggressive with
the other dogs and I think that's oh man
I think that's the hardest part is
because
since he's been a puppy he's so I mean
he's such a good dog and then we just we
can't take him outside of the gate and
it breaks our heart like all the time
yeah when do you notice his behavior
become more aggressive someone broke
into her house and these guys were in
the very backpack yeah
and that day we went back there and
Kawana once I went to her I was like hey
she went like this and then this guy did
one of these right and that wasn't their
character so we didn't know if something
was thrown at him whether it we don't
know what happened but there was
definitely a change in their personality
yeah shift we don't know if would that
cause some of this what's going on or
especially if you don't help them to
stabilize I believe dogs live in the
moment not in the past but sometimes
when they suffer a really traumatic
event
it's possible the dog can become fearful
aggressive and easily triggered
so as pet parents it is our job to
establish a sense of stability back into
their environment
if you don't you can actually make
things worse
but definitely you do have a case that
if he gets out it can hurt someone yeah
that's that's our worry let's just take
it for a walk Conrad show me how you
lead him let's go coming out all right
yeah
remember
foreign
whoa yeah he's really easily triggered
when you haven't easily triggered dog
that is the size and the strength of a
rottweiler it can be too much for most
people to handle Conrad is a big guy but
it's not his fault he's unable to
control all Kuma's power and volatility
I just need a minute with him let me
take him down the block
thank you
here let's get this harness out of you
hey
this aggressive Rottweiler which by the
way what you have is a territory or
Rottweiler oh okay oh okay yeah so what
he's doing is territorial I can see now
the real issue with Kuma after after the
break in he has become very territorial
meaning he gets aggressive when he feel
his territory has been invaded like when
I'm moving close to remove his harness
anything that gets near him he wants to
attack and makes a dangerous because
he's very territory to anything dogs
cats anything right okay because it's
such a powerful pack I need to bring
them to the safety of my Ranch to begin
their Rehabilitation we have to keep
working this is something that I would
like for you to do it as a couple only
okay you know so bring the pack of dogs
and leave the pack of kids behind I'm so
excited all right see you tomorrow see
you tomorrow tomorrow thank you sir
thank you
[Music]
no way there's a llama but there's a
herd of llamas yesterday when Caesar
said that Kum was a red case my heart
dropped I guess and I knew he was bad
but I didn't think he was that bad yeah
okay guys so this is a great opportunity
every time you move a dog from one place
to another place the new environment
gives them an open mind so it's easier
to get through to them okay everything
we're doing with Kuma is to work on his
territorial issues go through that door
over there look yeah take the leashes
off we want him to get comfortable in my
dog part so he feels like it is his
territory beautiful
okay coming in guys then I want to
introduce some of my most friendly
happy-go-lucky dogs in order to take
baby steps teaching Kuma that not
everything that approaches is a threat
let me get that
hey hold on wait now they're both
charging wanna relax we have to correct
her behavior first hey
[Music]
while working with Kuma a territorial
Rottweiler traumatized by a break-in at
the family home Caesar discovers
aggression from a different member of
this pack
hey I got it I got it
so she's been the boss for a while Moana
yeah so what we're finding right now
is that she is yeah yeah
now I can see that the old girl kuana
has taught her little brother Kuma how
to charge which could lead to aggression
it's possible her behavior is also a
result of the break-in but right now I
just need to get her under control hey
hey
there you go
there you go don't back away don't just
stand there support
you got to do the same thing we're doing
okay I didn't know if you want yeah
blocker
we need to block her she needs to sit
and surrender get your hands out of your
pocket
you must send them all the way to calm
surrender okay this is something that I
couldn't plan for it right because she
never did anything wrong yesterday yeah
now you know who taught him how to
behave how to how to like charge the
fans but you saw she went after me good
thing she had no teeth
[Music]
[Laughter]
charging is not particularly dangerous
what is dangerous is hakuma has adopted
that behavior now I want to see how he
behaves when we tether the older girl to
the fence to remove her from the
situation
the dogs in I want to see how Kuma
reacts
[Music]
hey he can charge
[Music]
there you go beautiful
hey hey
take hides behind her yeah that's right
that's his boss so she's packley here
yeah Kawana hastar Kuma his bad habit of
charging but we can see that even with
her tether he's still triggered by all
the activity we know Kumar has suffered
a trauma after the break-in so the only
way for him to re-stabilize is to get
the Comfort he needs from his pet
parents come this way
I want to show you something
look how much power she has over you
yeah he's just he's staying with her
staying with her instead of the human he
should choose a human but because she
gives them directions and she tells them
what to do and she has pretty much
raised him yeah you know from a dog
point of view that's why his loyalty is
to her oh that's amazing
we did not know that Kawana was the pack
leader at all she's actually the one
feeding the behavior to him so that was
a humbling experience for us because we
thought we were the Pack Leaders
my mind's still blown that he hasn't
come over to us yeah he's still standing
we were buddies
that's right bodies versus leader two
different things two different things if
you only buddies with your dog you're
never going to be able to snap them out
of this frightening mindset like this
breaking creative they see everyone as a
potential danger we have a bigger issue
than we thought yep fix this Conrad and
Lily need to head home and practice real
leadership by walking the dogs often
when encountering other people or other
dogs they should guide Kuma to sit
calmly and remain under the parents
leadership
while Conrad and Lily begin to work with
their dogs to re-establish trust and
security within the home
[Music]
meets with a couple whose dog is
constantly on the hunt
I'd be how you doing back there kiddo
Heidi what do you think
are you excited he's like I don't know
what's happening my name is Ryan I'm Kim
we have three kids three cats and two
dogs Coco and Lady Ivy our latest
addition
lady Ivy is 18 months old she's a pitsky
a pitbull husky mix We rescued Ivy
during the start of the pandemic since
we had the time she is in that puppy
phase rambunctious and just loving
the kids really have gotten attached to
Lady Ivy they love her great dog
interesting to see with ivy on a ranch
like this with squirrels and rabbits
that are running around see how she'll
react to that I'm excited to see what
Caesar can do yeah trying to get Ivy to
not kill our other pets that would be
nice
we live on a property that is perfect
for a large dog lots of wildlife on our
property but if she sees a squirrel a
bird a rabbit on the street she just
takes off 110 miles an hour hey stay
with me it's this Instinct that she has
that really kind of takes over and gets
a bit scary
does this leap in the air pounces on the
squirrel and then one shake of her head
takes him apart
it's always a bloody mess
and now we're afraid our cats might be
next
we've had lady ivy for eight months and
that whole time the cats have been
sequestered in our bedroom because if
she does get near them she tears off
after them and Chaos ensues
one time a cat got loose from our
bedroom and they were sort of growling
at each other and Lady Ivy pounced just
like she would when attacking an animal
and so I dove on Ivy rolled her off a
while getting bit on my arm blood
trickling down my hands and arms the cat
took off and we kind of avoided disaster
but it was a close call if you didn't
close the master bedroom door it could
mean the cat's lives
we love her she's so sweet and such a
good part of the family but if we can't
get this to work out we're going to have
to re-home Ivy so we're hoping that this
works
we need a bit of a miracle it would be
very very difficult to let this kid go
all right guys we're gonna meet Caesar
here we go guys
so I'll get
hi good morning good morning
good morning how are you pleasure to
meet you get him out okay let's go
hi sweetie
hi sweetie oh yes here we go
oh okay he's pulling it's just like this
all the time correct yeah
her mind is somewhere else yeah already
somewhere else yeah yeah so the only way
that you can hold it here is because you
have a leash on she looks like she wants
to run off and hunt
the dog was pulling on the leash the
moment it was out of the car already on
the hunt her mind was not here with us
because her prey dry was an Overdrive
so I want to test the limits of that
drive by introducing the largest spray
animal she's ever seen can we get here
let's go for a little walk with it
we know she likes to hunt squirrels and
rabbits but carefully observing how she
interacts with Marty will help us
understand how deep her problem goes so
we're gonna bring the donkey and her to
walk together okay
to make sure everything is safe I'm
gonna hold both lines and stand like a
barrier between them
the person in the middle needs to be
calm confident because she's anxious her
whole prey drive
this is mental
it's like a Formula One driver the one
that's adrenaline 200 miles an hour
I'm down
there is the prey drive getting too
excited it's not allowed
I'm down Caesar works with Ivy a pitsky
whose history of hunting and killing
small animals threatens the family cats
to assess the level of her prey drive
Caesar introduces his largest prey
animal Marty the Donkey
there is a freight ride getting too
excited
hey
it's not allowed
he has learned to chase the Predator is
the one who is in the hunt that she
needs to go back to domesticated dog
she's definitely tapping into her prey
drive but we always knew that that was a
possibility now the important thing is
to see if she stays in that headspace or
if we can calm her down so she doesn't
see Marty as prey progresa
let's see if we can remove the
predatorial state so like like when you
walk in and you're and somebody's coming
just
so what we're doing is letting her know
to Chase is not an option
and when you're passing by another
animal you want to be in between right I
mean it's easier right
so so instead of you saying leave it
drop it don't do it
you breathe and you visualize exactly
how you want it to happen
you're asking her to wait and wait
patiently wait patiently so that becomes
more mental
I understand you're a hunter but we
don't want that in the city yeah right
this dog is not an aggressive dog she's
constantly on the hunt because it's like
she's addicted to the adrenaline rush
she gets from chasing prey but he's
pulling her mind is somewhere else but
we have to teach her there is a time and
place for that and to show her how to
turn it off instead of going 200 miles
an hour all the time all right let's go
back so to do that I'm going to need to
get a better understanding of the
situation at home
we need a path forward so that normal
life can be what it should be over the
past nine months we have kept our cats
in our master bedroom we'd like to keep
our doors open we'd like to be one big
family and right now our family is
separate
I feel like at some point it's going to
turn into a mess or a death I've been
working at home you know for nine or ten
months and I'm a little worried about
going back into my office right now I
have to be in the house just to kind of
make sure everything is okay
you get to the point where
you can't go any further your cats don't
feel safe
no right we definitely have to take care
of the Instinct of Ivy yeah she's
hunting and her hunting means kill right
yeah you know you have not been able to
connect her to your cats so the cats are
you know game for her yeah the problem
with keeping Ivy separating from the
cats and she will never get used to them
they're not part of her pack they are
game
this entire pack needs to be unified but
they're not ready for that before I see
them again I want them to practice their
homework instead of keeping the cats
behind closed doors I want them to open
them up but keep the protective Gates
Ivy and the cats need to see each other
while Kim Ryan and the kids keep a
control calm energy without becoming
tense like they have been this is how
dogs and cats start to see each other as
something other than predator and prey
sounds great thank you guys appreciate
it
good boy Kuma we had some homework
Caesar wanted us to take Kuma out on a
pack walk with the family look how good
he's doing son right making sure that
Kuma's following us instead of Kawana
he's not even paying attention to her
look he's locked in on you yeah I I
think he's definitely stopped deferring
to Kawana and he sees us as the leaders
now but Kuma's still being territorial
he's still charging the fence we we need
some insight on on how to fix that
thank you
good morning sexual unusual weather here
at the DPC it's nice and hot today yes
listen I can control animals but I can
control weather all right should we
bring them out bring them out bring them
out after watching the homework you can
see Kuma is now following Conrad and
Lily instead of Kawana but his
territorial aggression is a learned
behavior and he's been doing it whether
the old girl is present or not is his
most dangerous Behavior so to address it
we need to isolate him good let's go
there we go in his dog park Caesar will
introduce large breed dogs that Kuma may
feel threatened by if the dog reacts
aggressively Conrad and Lily need to
show leadership using their energy to
block him and snap him out of the
territorial mindset you can take the
muzzle off come here buddy
the reason why I ask you to take the
muscle off because he's in a good state
of mind and the memory
that he had here before I want it back
got it Caesar tells us let's take off
the muzzle but I'm nervous not knowing
how Kuma is going to respond let's get
to work we've never had Kuma without a
muzzle around people or other dogs all
right let's get him in there so I'm
definitely nervous
all right let's get a dog
explaining his territory watch out
all right let's get a dog Caesar works
with Kuma a two-year-old Rottweiler
who's grown increasingly aggressive
after her break-in at the family home
to address the dog's territorial
aggression
Caesar must teach him that not
everything he encounters is the threat
let's go correct him
no charging
can you Corner him and then get him over
here
now he's back yet but then he goes to do
it over here
okay that's better
Come a Little Closer Ariana
the brain's still over there
we go nice wow beautiful teamwork by the
way beautiful beautiful now we're seeing
some real progress Conrad and Lily
physically block Kuma to snap him out of
his territorial mindset which brought
him to calm surrender they don't even
know what this dog is truly capable of
so now I need to show them that with
their guidance Kuma has the ability to
go from feeling like he's constantly
threatened to a gentle giant
like come over here
Kuma
come on
you create the calm surrender and then
you call them away don't call them away
when he's excited okay all right let's
do it again that's what I was gonna ask
if we can do it again perfect let's get
another dog
look at that that's beautiful good boy
that's right his chest is not tense you
know his head is not high you can see
the smile in the face once the pet
parents corrected him they were able to
get him to a calm surrender from that
point forward he didn't even need a
correction when the other dogs walked by
how cool is that the strategy is
incredible super proud of you guys
look at that
when it comes to dogs look he's already
saying dog means happy-go-lucky when we
started with Kuma it was clear his
territorialism was triggered by dogs
and also people and children his dog
reactivity is improving you can see the
family has hope again so I want to send
them home to continue blocking him
anytime he gets triggered work with this
at home okay come back with the family
all right I can see you guys bye
everyone ready
foreign
working with Caesar we've been doing a
lot of work with Ivy getting her to
surrender and be calm
what you think we've seen little
glimpses of her being the right frame of
mind to be able to meet the cats lady
Ivy and the cats were making eye contact
and we've avoided disaster
but it was a tense moment
still nerve-wracking it's really a life
or death situation
Caesar welcomes Kim Ryan and their
children back to the DPC to work on the
next step of Lady Ivy's Rehabilitation
this way are we going into the chickens
and the Ducks lady Ivey has been hunting
her whole life and now she's hunting the
family cats
I say this is your classic case of dog
versus cat but Ivy is capable of some
real damage now the covet lockdowns are
starting to lift Ryan is heading back to
the office soon so Kim is a matrix of
the house today is all about changing
her energy which can be a little tense
into a calm confident leadership at the
same time we're safely lowering Ivy
spray drive by desensitizing her to the
animals we know she normally loves to
hunt now don't let her stop just keep
going
come on
she doesn't want to go come on there you
go there you go don't hesitate don't
make it it has permission
don't worry about the Ducks you stay
calm she stays calm
good keep going
relax the arm
wait wait wait wait wait
so watch this so what happens is you
kept your arm tense okay look
you see it yeah so she relaxes then yeah
because this becomes like a tense moment
but if you keep it tense then she's
gonna feel like the tense okay Kim goes
from hesitation to tense and the dog can
feel this which keeps her in an agitated
or excited state and leads to Adrenaline
seeking behaviors like hunting go around
the docks right there go around again
yeah
relax the arm
[Music]
beautiful now you see how she's ignoring
the Ducks
did you guys see that that is amazing
[Music]
all right
to me
that's my art
look at that yes
yes I'm shocked that Ivy made it through
this little Gauntlet of the chickens and
Ducks I can't believe that she didn't at
least attempt to bolt at the at the
Ducks I'm really proud of how calm she
was and how she was able to respect the
space of the animals that was remarkable
that's a calm surrender customer
like I'm done yes
now that we've shown Kim and Ryan that
lady ivy can achieve calm surrender both
the dog and the family are ready to
finally Unite with the cats we know how
powerful her hunting instincts are so we
must still be cautious
[Music]
the next morning Caesar arrives at the
liljigrin home and prepares the family
to finally introduce lady Ivy to their
cats alright so we're here for your
final test Kim are you gonna pass by the
bedroom first the whole point is for her
breakfast avoidance come surrender to
you once your practice come surrender
then we went inside Kim needs to walk
Ivy upstairs and get her into a calm
surrender State before entering the room
with the cats if she enters before Ivy
is settle it could be chaos so also
we're going to use the muzzle just to
keep it safe and everybody else is going
to go inside with the cats so we're
going to do it as a pack sounds good
cool I'm nervous about what this is
going to look like when we do introduce
her to the cats so hopefully no one gets
hurt but it's definitely a
nerve-wracking
okay
all right Kim let's do this
[Music]
oh that's bad that was bad
all right so we're here for your final
test lady Ivy is a nine month old pitsky
with a predisposition to hunt small
animals including the family cats after
working with pet parent Kint to
de-stress and bring balance to both her
home and Ivy
Caesar's final challenge is for Kim to
remain calm and safely introduce the dog
and cats all right Kim let's do this
the danger has progressed around the
cats if we can't figure this situation
out we would have to re-home lady Ivy at
this point
that was bad lady Ivey walked into the
door and did that
so that should be snapped out of it
that's bad
there's alert tense
you have to help lady
you can see the tension
[Music]
see she's correcting her over there but
she's correcting it over here he needs
to correct her by the entrance because
when she's got the door
at the moment she does this I'm gonna
correct her and she's gonna go right
back to a calm surrender state so it's
catching there in that moment it's
absolutely essential that Kim can get
Ivy into a calm surrender state right
before entering the room with the cats
look Kim yes when she's coming in she's
coming in with the head height forward
so that's not good Kim needs to pay
close attention to Ivy's ears and tail
to make sure they're down instead of up
that's how she's going to know the IV is
ready to enter the room I just want you
to watch the behavior yes yeah the hello
and the tail down if that's what you
want
ready
so come down and come up yeah
ready
[Music]
get there stop it right there do you
have to sit there already gears are up
now stop her out of it with the touch
there you go those are yours right there
there we go perfect
[Music]
that's perfect
yes
love that face
yeah
I'm loving.com energy Kim
's energy is what made the difference
today when she started she was tense but
she found the confidence to make a real
connection with Ivy and calmly lead her
into the room now Ivy is not hunting the
cats America just showing respect to the
distance eventually she wouldn't even
need the muscle that's how you transform
an adrenally junking Hunter into a calm
member of the pack you can see it right
the body language is good it was great
having everyone in the room together and
working together all with the kids and
with the cats and just getting that
Unity of the whole pack the whole family
and help Ivy be assimilated into the
family instead of being on the outside
oh yeah I'm really happy we don't have
to re-home live she's my favorite dog
Caesar thank you so much for giving us
all these tools to work with Ivy so that
we can have Harmony in our home
[Music]
our homework was to work with Kuma with
his aggression running towards the gate
or showing any type of territorial
aggression
hold on I think we're doing a good job
but I don't think we're there yet hey
this is hard sometimes because he's so
big and he's so strong so I feel like
I'm a little scared to get in front of
him because I feel like he's gonna
tumble me over so
um I think I need to work on that
the following day
dear welcomes back the Luhan family and
their two-year-old Rottweiler Kuma all
right guys
let's say hi
you see I've arrived
the queen herself is here
when they first met Kuma showed
territorial aggression towards strangers
and members of his own pack including
children
for the family to trust the dog has
transformed Caesar must put him to a
final series of tests coming in you guys
ready to cheer up Daddy
I know we created this little obstacle
course for you Brothers okay we're gonna
have some distractions okay the kids are
going to be some without distractions
that's a big distraction uh dogs as well
and some bikes let me explain to you
what we're gonna do this is home my
front yard okay I need you to stay
focused no matter what okay calmness is
key okay you're gonna have Kuma okay
coming with you you're gonna have it on
the leash okay put him here all of this
is part of it for the final challenge
Conrad needs to guy Kuma through an
obstacle course overrun with
distractions I want kids dogs chaos
everywhere so then Kuma is going to come
here you can ask him to sit down then
with the leash you're gonna go around we
need to surround Kuma with everything
that once triggered him to ensure that
he can be trusted and that contract can
provide the calm confident leadership
this dog needs
I'm gonna go get the pack all right Lou
and family no touch no talking eye
contact okay coming back I'm adding my
pack to the environment to see how Kuma
responds to humans and dogs and his
space
if Kuma's territorial Behavior has not
been refocused it will be exposed in
this final exercise
[Music]
he's getting too excited they're all
surround him block him block him
come on help
I'm gonna go get the pack Rottweiler
Kuma grew territorial after a burglary
at the family home watch his reaction
easily triggered by distractions the dog
shows dangerous Behavior toward both
dogs and children
Caesar must present Kuma with his most
challenging environment yet to test
whether the dog can once again be
trusted
he's getting too excited goes around him
block him block him
come up hey
before we can even begin Kuma is
triggered by all the activity got it
help help corner
all right I got used to it
that's beautiful but he needs to go all
the way
from the sit right
you can also push a little bit of the
back
good job boys
I can see the family has taken their
homework seriously now they're working
together to calm Kuma so I feel
confident he's ready to be near my pack
this is like the equivalent of being at
the dog park but a cool dog park so that
allows your dog to focus in this regard
what is happening see look how good my
boy is doing yes he's ready for the test
all right let's go
for Kuma to be trusted in the family
home he needs to demonstrate perfect
obedience throughout this final
challenge
these dogs they're all understand social
distance the obstacle course is set up
as one hurdle followed by a resting
platform and so on Conrad must keep Kuma
perfectly focused despite of all the
activity and chaos
zero triggers and we got a rehabilitated
Rottweiler
don't lose your patience there we go
come here boy
that's it
there you go EPA there we go yes
all right see
it's okay
yeah
so what's happening right now is the
energy comes down now Conrad is in
control
your energy is your most powerful tool
on this planet
you understand my friend
doing good
that's it
[Music]
you ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
right now I feel really excited that was
a big achievement for me and we're all
excited for you too oh thanks
say Go Daddy when we first started Kumar
was looking at Guana as pack leader
taking his cues from her
she's staying with her staying with her
instead of the human you should choose
the humans and now he's completely
focused on Conrad and Lily who have
reestablished themselves as Leaders of
this pack not a surprise for the
princess the whole pack is going to come
with us and my boy is gonna pull the car
oh so the car is the extra challenge
Rottweilers are car dogs they can pull
things they were bred for that this is
how we reward let's go let's go let's go
in the beginning we didn't think it was
possible to trust Kuma with the children
but because of this process we've been
able to regain trust in him you know
we're still working on that we'll
continue to work on it continue to build
that trust we're learning and we're
growing I think it was quite quite
successful both of you my name is a good
job
[Music]
come on
there is no quick fix for a case like
this but seeing the commitment Conrad
and Lily had made to stabilize Kuma
after that dramatic break-in that tells
me this family will conquer any
challenge if they do it together
[Applause]
sometimes it's impossible to completely
forget the traumas from our past look at
that righty babe but by facing them head
on and working through them together we
find a way to move forward and become a
healthier safer and much stronger pack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]